es el producto más vendido en Indonesia
la razón no es solamente que las mujeres
quieren vestir recatadamente
sino también que ahora está de moda
antes no lo era
hoy en día las mujeres siguen vistiendo
recatadamente pero con estilo
[Música]
la moda es Fashion es una tendencia
interreligiosa en el vestir que
prescribe claramente las mujeres vestir
de forma discreta ahora se dirige a un
público mucho más amplio y es un negocio
en expansión una panorámica del fenómeno
con diseñadores de moda internacionales
e influencers reunidos durante la
segunda edición de la semana de la moda
recatada de París
cuando mi hermana se casó no sabíamos
exactamente qué queríamos para ella para
el gran día y eso fue lo que realmente
nos hizo pensar si no podemos
encontrarlos nosotros mismos pues lo
crearemos
porque la moda recatada como puedes ver
mi hermana lleva el velo yo no Por qué
una lleva el velo y la otra no así que
después de eso es una elección personal
quizás por nuestra doble cultura
en efecto nuestro padre es de origen
pennecino nuestra madre es de origen
francés así que tenemos estas dos
influencias que intentamos transcribir
en nuestros vestidos en nuestras
creaciones pienso que es una riqueza que
está muy presente en Francia y que en mi
opinión aún no explotamos lo suficiente
creo que eso es lo que estamos tratando
de reflejar en mesoamán tener esta
riqueza en nuestras creaciones diseños
que mezclan el lado Oriental y el
occidental y también nos representa
la moda es un sutil juego entre Mostrar
y esconder en la moda recatada este
Equilibrio es peculiar
por ejemplo Esta es una especie de
túnica es larga a la espalda Es muy muy
larga y la parte delantera es un poco
abierta a los lados esto permite a la
mujer adecuada llevar por ejemplo
leggings o pantalones nunca hay piernas
descubiertas nunca mi punto de vista es
que esto es lo que se le debe poner a la
mujer con velo no otra cosa o más bien
de la mujer pudorosa porque ahora hay
muchas mujeres que aunque no sean
musulmanas usando ropa pudorosa ocultan
sus curvas ocultan algo ocultan su pelo
en este desfile hay looks que son muy
modernos chaquetas con pantalones anchos
manteniendo el turbante y un cuello alto
que se puede quitar y poner Qué quiere
decir eso quiere decir que puede ponerse
una camisa como está abierta tranquila
como está y adapté un pequeño cuello de
tortuga llega hasta aquí así como así un
buzo de cuello alto que va con el
turbante es moderno y pueda quitárselo Y
ponérselo de nuevo Lo que significa que
una mujer sin velo pueda ponérselo una
mujer con velo puede Añadir un turbante
Así que adaptó a todas las mujeres
[Música]
Cómo empezó a trabajar con trajes de
baño
es una idea que tengo en mente desde
hace mucho tiempo hay que saber que
cuando llega el verano muchas mujeres
tienen el problema de encontrar la
prenda veraniega perfecta
no te gusta tanto el término burkini
No es que no me guste el término
es que mucha gente piensa que el burkini
es un bañador que no tiene cortes
modernos
hay varias nociones en este conjunto de
baños
y también hay gente que quiere cubrirse
para protegerse del Sol
de hecho en verano
[Música]
qué hago de hecho yo lo llamo de hecho
es arte reciclado en el que voy a
reutilizar objetos en nuestra vida
cotidiana que ya no usamos por ejemplo
por ejemplo aquí como el papel de
aluminio recogí todo el papel de
aluminio que llevaba meses estirado
también trabajé con 150 botellas de agua
de plástico que dieron este cuadro y que
posteriormente dieron este motivo que
está aquí Así que lo que hago es crearme
pintura en un Lienzo luego creo mi
textura después transfiero esa textura
digitalmente a una sarga de seda para
que pueda vestir una obra
cree que algún día todas las mujeres
podrán llevar exactamente lo que quieran
Eso espero lo deseo creo que cada vez
estamos más cerca sobre todo ahora que
la industria de la moda recatada se
acerca a la industria de la moda normal
creo que con este cambio Espero y siento
que será algo normal
que puedas ir totalmente cubierta o no
que una mujer pueda vestir y hacer lo
que quiera porque al fin y al cabo todo
es cuestión de criterio
no es asunto mío lo que hagan las demás
y no es asunto suyo lo que haga una
mujer así que sí de verdad de verdad
espero que suceda
que cada mujer pueda llevar lo que
quiera
Mientras tanto la moda recatada se
encuentra en una situación paradójica
supuestamente nos llama la atención Pero
hoy está en la mira